Jason recorrió en bicicleta desde su casa
hasta la estación del tren
con una rapidez
de 10 kilómetros por hora.
Después, abordó el tren y viajó hasta la
ciudad con una rapidez promedio de 50 km/h.
Si la distancia total del viaje fue de 30 km
y el viaje en total duró 1 hora,
¿cuántos kilómetros viajo Jason en tren?
Así que lo primero que voy a hacer es definir
variables y voy a decir que "d" subíndice "t",
es la cantidad de distancia que viajo
Jason en tren...
la distancia que viajó Jason en tren...
y por lo tanto, de manera análoga,
"d" subíndice "b"
voy a decir que es la distancia que viajo
Jason en bicicleta...
la distancia que recorrió en bicicleta.
Muy bien, ahora que ya tengo
estas dos nuevas variables,
yo sé que la distancia total fue
de 30 kilómetros,
por lo tanto, si yo sumo
estas dos distancias, tiene que ser igual a 30,
la distancia que viajo Jason en tren
más la distancia que viajó Jason en bicicleta,
esto tiene que ser igual a 30.
Y ojo, como todo está dado en kilómetros
y todo está dado en horas,
no voy a tener que cambiar unidades.
Ahora, después me dice
que el viaje entero duró una hora
y seguramente en este momento me vas a decir,
oh no, pero estamos hablando
de tiempo y por lo tanto tendríamos que meter
2 nuevas variables, el tiempo del tren y el
tiempo de la bicicleta,
sin embargo, lo que quiero que recordemos e
s una fórmula que hemos
visto varias veces en los videos de física,
que dice que la distancia
es igual a la rapidez  por el tiempo
y si divido ambos lados entre la rapidez,
me quedaría que el tiempo
es igual a la distancia entre la rapidez.
El tiempo es igual a la distancia entre la
rapidez y justo esto voy a utilizar porque entonces
puedo ver el tiempo como una función
de la distancia que es justo lo que quiero.
Fíjate bien, el tiempo del tren es igual,
según esta fórmula, a la distancia del tren
entre la rapidez promedio
que hicimos en el tren,
pero ese dato me lo dan,
la rapidez promedio
que hicimos en el tren,
es de 50 km/h,
por lo tanto como todo está en kilómetros
y todo está en horas,
voy a dividir entre 50,
el tiempo del tren
es igual a la distancia del tren entre 50
y  de igual manera si yo
pienso en la bicicleta,
el tiempo en la bicicleta
va a ser la distancia de la bicicleta entre
la rapidez promedio que hicimos en la bicicleta,
que fueron 10 km/h, perfecto.
Y ya que tengo esas dos,
entonces yo sé que la suma del tiempo del tren,
más la suma del tiempo en la bicicleta,
tiene que ser igual a 1 hora,
este dato es muy importante,
porque entonces me voy a tomar
la suma de estos dos tiempos,
pero en función de la distancia
y lo voy a hacer igual a 1 hora,
entonces este dato
es muy importante y voy
a utilizar estas
dos ecuaciones que tengo aquí.
Y entonces que ecuación me va a quedar
de sumar estos dos tiempos...
vamos a escribirlo aquí abajo
con un nuevo color...
Bueno, que la distancia del tren entre 50,
esto estoy hablando del tiempo del tren,
más la distancia de la bicicleta entre 10,
estoy hablando del tiempo de la bicicleta,
esto tiene que ser igual a 1 hora,
es lo que me
dice este renglón.
Y ojo, no te confundas, lo único que hice
fue tomarme la suma de los dos tiempos,
del tiempo del tren
y del tiempo de la bicicleta,
pero los sustituí
como funciones de la distancia
para que así me queden dos ecuaciones
con dos incógnitas y entonces pueda
encontrar la solución de este problema,
es decir, la distancia que recorremos el tren,
eso es justo lo que yo quiero,
tras de esta variable vamos.
Y bueno, la forma más sencilla de resolver
esto y lo que se me ocurre, es...
mira, si yo tengo la ecuación de arriba tal
cual y yo lo gro que la ecuación de abajo
tenga aquí un menos la distancia en bicicleta,
entonces podría sumar estas dos ecuaciones.
Así que mejor déjame poner esta ecuación
de aquel lado, la distancia del tren,
más la distancia de la bicicleta es igual a 30
y por otra parte, ésta,
ésta de aquí es la que quiero convertir en menos
la distancia de la bicicleta.
Y bueno, la forma más fácil de hacerlo,
es multiplicar esta ecuación de ambos lados por -10,
si yo multiplico a esta ecuación
de ambos lados por -10, voy a obtener lo que quiero.
Fíjate bien, cuando yo multiplique por -10
y divida entre 10,
me va a quedar -1 y -1
por la distancia de la bicicleta
es justo lo que quiero,
entonces,
¿qué me queda de esto?
Bueno, 10 entre 50
es lo mismo que 1/5,
pero con este signo menos
me va a quedar -1/5 de la distancia del tren
y después me queda,
-10 entre 10, esto es igual a -1,
por la distancia de la bicicleta,
entonces me queda menos la distancia de la bicicleta, esto es igual a -10.
Muy bien,
y yo quería hacer la distancia
de la bicicleta negativa, para que ahora si,
pueda resolver este sistema de ecuaciones
por el método de suma y resta
de una manera bastante sencilla,
porque yo voy a sumar estas dos ecuaciones
y esto se va a cancelar,
entonces me queda la distancia del tren menos 1/5
de la distancia del tren...
bueno, la distancia del tren es lo mismo que
5/5 de la distancia del tren,
menos 1/5 de la distancia del tren
me queda 4/5 de la distancia del tren...
4/5 de la distancia del tren,
esto es igual a 30 menos 10,
lo cual es 20
y ahora si yo lo que quiero saber
es la distancia del tren
y tengo una fracción,
pues tengo que multiplicar
por el recíproco de una fracción, pero el
recíproco de una fracción es muy sencillo,
lo único que hay que hacer es pasar el denominador
al numerador y el numerador al denominador
y entonces voy a multiplicar por 5/4 de ambos
lados de la ecuación,
entonces, estos dos se cancelan
y me queda que la distancia del
tren es igual a 20 por 5/4
y bueno, si yo divido 20 entre 4,
entonces éste de aquí me da 5
y 4 entre 4 me da 1 y entonces me queda
5 por 5 lo cual es 25.
Perfecto, la distancia del tren
es 25 kilómetros,
que es justo lo que yo quería,
éste es el resultado de mi problema
y además con esta distancia del tren,
podré obtener todo lo demás,
la distancia de la bicicleta,
los dos tiempos, etc...
Y más aún, de esta ecuación puedo obtener
de una manera muy sencilla que la distancia
de la bicicleta tiene que ser 5 km.